Now I did say that we need to look at what happens at the edges of the image.
So let's look at that specific example.
Again, the same image except that this time around I've replaced the zeros with
some numeric values.
Again just to help us see what would happen.
Again, my output.
And I've filled it out again,
the middle part as we've done in the previous frame.
So now we have to start thinking about how do we fill the edge cases out?
Again, doing my filtering using a three by three, which we will rub over.
And we did that.
Now, of course I still don't have any values here.
To achieve that what I need to do is basically pad this image with
additional information.
So to achieve that basically what I would do in this instance, as long as I
am actually looking at a three by three neighborhood, I need to add one
neighborhood pixel, or one column or one row, and make this image bigger by one.
Of course, if my kernel or my size of the filter that I'm looking at is bigger
that 3, let's say five by five, then I will have to add three different rows and
columns to be able to give it more information so I can fill this out.
So once I put this up, I need to also fill it out with values.
One thing we can do is basically take these values and copy them over.
So, basically, just copying them over actually gives us more information here.
This one can also be then copied over, or some sort of simple numerical method,
like an average of this could be used to do replace this value here.
So now I've actually basically created a new image that's a little
bigger than my original image.
Now I just mirroring and copying this over.
And once I do this,
I can now run the process which allows me to fill in values here.
So now basically suggests is that I can take this three by three and
when I apply it here, the value would be filling out here.
And similarly, this way all of this, this, and this would also be filled out.
Of course, there will be degradation of information.
Most of the pixel values here would not, of course, be completely correct.
Because we're kind of synthet,
synthesizing a buffer to be able to do this type of filtering.
There are many strategies usually available how we
can actually add this information.
So some of the options of doing this is we can wrap the information around,
as we kind of did, or we can just copy it from one to the other.
Or we can reflect information across making this be the axes and
take these values and move them around.
Again many different methods can be used.
What we're really trying to do is figure out how to increase the edge size so
we can basically do computation of this and create a newer image from it.
Of course there is significant error accumulated in doing this because
the edges will start loosing information as you can start making bigger and
bigger filter kernels.
Of course remember again if I were to do five by five what will have to
add two layer, two rows and two columns, and
make a bigger image to be able to then fill in values.
We will see examples of that as we do start doing image processing.
That some of the information at the edges does start getting to
be suspicious and lost.